all right thank you
um for the opportunity to speak to you
today so I'm going to talk for a few
minutes about
weed management and strawberries
and
just to put a few kind of qualifiers on
here I'm going to summarize what we do
in Florida first for weed management so
that means everything that I'm talking
about is in regards to plastic culture
production although a lot of the
techniques do go beyond that
um
I'm going to kind of frame this around
an integratedly matched program because
one thing we have found is that no
single tool will solve the problem but
you've got to integrate a bunch of them
so I'm going to spend a little bit more
time on some components of this than
others
but uh we're going to highlight some of
the things we found the last few years
but also highlight kind of the standard
practices here in Florida
so to start with we're going to start
with fumigation the vast majority of
strawberries in Florida are fumigated we
do have around anywhere from six to
eight hundred acres of organic
strawberries
um in the county where I'm at which is
Hillsborough County
and that kind of varies depend from year
to year depending on the market
but as far as fumigation goes we just
completed a management survey a short
while ago
and the most common fumigant in Florida
when strawberries is pickle or 60.
and as commonly thought of for control
of pathogens and nematodes it does
provide some weed control as well which
I'll talk about a little bit in a minute
telephone c35 used to be the most common
fumigant but it's no longer as common as
and then there are a few Growers that
use k-pam or vapeam as well which its
strong point is weed control
the
one of the reasons that we use these
combinations of tone and chloropicarine
is because of the fact in terms of weed
control they're much more effective when
combined now these pictures I'm going to
show you the next couple pictures are in
tomatoes but you see the same Trend in
strawberries so the pitcher on the left
is your non-treated
and you can see nut sedge coming through
the plastic here if you add 50 pounds of
chloropicrin it depends a pick you
actually make the problem worse and
that's because low levels of pick will
stimulate not such sprouting if you get
up around 200 pounds of pick well then
you've certainly reduced the population
compared to a non-treated but you don't
get great control
if you look at same picture on the left
as untreated the middle that's still 50
pounds a pick but the picture on the
right now this is 15 gallons per acre
one 3D it essentially doesn't have any
effect on that side's control
on its own but this is where you really
see the difference once you combine the
pick in the one 3D you see a really
clean bed and it's that combination of
products that gives optimizes weed
control and we see that consistently
across all crops and
um the that combination improves control
now
here is a key point though is this
really weather dependent so those
pictures that I'm showing you where we
get really good control of nutsedge
those are fumigated in January in
Florida so that's when the soil is a bit
cooler if you look at this picture on
the left is Pickler 60 on the right is
non-fumigated almost no difference those
are fumigated in it's a lie when it's
really hot so we for weed control when
it comes to fumigation
you have to take into account whether
cooler slightly cooler soils are going
to give you better weed control just
because the fuming it moves through the
soil more slowly
we've done a lot of long-term fumigation
trials the last few years and I'm not
going to spend a lot of time on this
because communication is not kind of
where I want to spend all the time but I
do want to point out this picture to
give an example on the left is
non-fumigated on the right is Pickler
60.
and again on the left is not fumigated
on the right it's the Florida three-way
what we call the Florida three-way is a
combination so indicate in this case
Pickler 60 plus k-pam on the top and
early in the season you don't see a lot
of a lot of difference but when you move
through
um late in the season you see where we
didn't fumigate we just got hammered
with disease Pickler 60 did fairly well
but there's a lot of variability in
those plants
if you look at this three-way a picture
on the right you see consistency just to
show you another picture of how extreme
this can be we don't use Paladin anymore
but this still shows the difference of
the Florida three-way versus not the
bottom left-hand pitcher that's power
and pick 21 you can see all those
grasses and broadleaf weeds growing in
there
this is the same field here we have
Paladin plus k-pam and you can see how
much cleaner it is so consistently if we
have a problem field that's going to be
fumigated that has a lot of weeds the
Florida three-way or what Georgia they
call it the Georgia three-way that
combination gives you the best control
and in our studies it actually gives you
the best economic return as well
so real quick
use combinations if you fumigate
cooler temperatures are going to give
you better weed control
with four or three ways the best in
terms of weed control as well as
economic return and it's the best in
terms of broadleaf and Brass control as
well
when it comes to herbicides so
I'm going to talk about some
pre-herbicized pre-emergent server size
the ones that you apply before the weeds
are up so in our in Florida we're going
to talk about herbicides that go
underneath the plastic mulch so
[Music]
you can have this equipment you can see
here which is a bed press which has
nozzles on the back which can spray the
herbicide directly on the bed
immediately before we lay the plastic
this is not a real common practice in
Florida not a lot of people are using
herbicides under the plastic
it does occur
especially in fields where there are
problems with broadleaf grass weeds
here is a summary of the most common
herbicides used in Florida historically
the recommendation was a combination of
gold and Evernote uh we've moved away
from that
Chateau is now the most common
recommendation and there's a few reasons
for that if you look down this is just a
few wheat species that we have in
Florida strawberries
and black medic and Carolina geranium
are two common ones you see Chateau
provides some suppression of those two
species where's the other two products
do not
um generally speaking Chateau persists a
little longer and provides really good
excellent weed control of most species a
little bit better than gold although
gold was also a very good product
you might be wondering why historically
would they have mixed gold and ever and
all well that's simple this next chart
shows it devinol is much better on
grasses than Chateau orgoal so that Gold
Plus Denver and all mix gave you a
better
um overall we control however Chateau is
pretty decent better than gold on
grasses and the last pricing I did which
was admittedly a little over a year ago
but it was so prices changed a lot but
at the time Chateau was at around twenty
dollars per acre a gold devron all mix
costs around 120 dollars per acre so a
big difference in cost which is why
we've kind of moved away from that mix
and settled on Chateau is the best
option
unfortunately neither one of the none of
these products work on nutsedge there
are no effective herbicides registered
for nutsedge control and strawberry
just a real quick blurb on flumioxism
which is the active ingredient in
chateau
um this chart right here we did this
trial a short time ago looking at the
red labeled rates which is 1x all the
way up to ridiculously high rates
something that you would never use we
were just trying to highlight
um what rate would you have to use to
see damage and we did this across a lot
of different sites and you can see I'm
pointing at these dots where the One X
rate which is three ounces per acre two
x-rayed or the 4X rate this is
essentially no damage you have to go all
the way up to eight times the label rate
to cause damage and Chateau so it's
extremely safe if you do get damaged
this is what it looks like Chateau if
you get it on the bed and it comes up
through the roots you can see the
Browning on the veins that's what
Chateau will do it'll burn the veins up
and of course that leaf will die
if you have real high rates on the plant
is not likely going to recover
this graph is Chateau persistence over
the season and I know it goes up a
little bit here but it's just kind of a
little bit of accumulation effect but
basically the reason we like Chateau is
because the fact it persists throughout
our season so it's a really good product
just a couple of things
um strawberries are extremely tolerant
of Chateau you can apply it don't of
course but you we went up to four times
the label right without any damage it
persists for the whole season that's a
good thing unless you're going to use
that plastic for a second crop then
that's could be a problem for you
um I have gone to a few Fields over the
last few years where we
um saw some Chateau damage and the three
bullet points in the bottom here these
are the three reasons we've seen damage
number one inadequate agitation in the
tank so Chateau right now is a granular
although that formulation is changing
and there's been cases where people
didn't agitate it the elves and you
release a clump of herbicide in the
middle of the field and you get a you
know a spot where you get some damage
you have an inexperienced driver who
slows down near the end of the roads and
you get really high rates near the end
of the row that can happen or Chateau is
supposed to be put on the top of the bed
right before you lay the plastic there's
been a few people sprayed on the flat
and pull that bed up and you end up with
a concentrated lines of herbicide right
where the plants are and that also can
cause damage
now most of the herbicides that are used
in strawberries are used in the Raw
Metals
um and that's
pretty well every single grower does
apply herbicides in their own Metals in
Florida except for the organic Growers
which tend to rely on cultivation
we've done a lot of trials in different
crops looking at which herbicides are
the most effective
and this is just a table showing two
different seasons and this was weed
density in the row middle and you can
see Chateau consistently dropped weed
death density significantly dual Chateau
and dual and gold did fairly well but
not really any any better than Chateau
alone
I mentioned dual because it's recently
been registered in strawberries in
Florida I don't believe it's registered
in Alabama
but I'll just we can use it in their own
middle I'm not 100 sure of it in Alabama
um
this is an example of a role model this
is again this particular one was in
tomatoes but you can see non-treated
versus Chateau application we had your
maximum exterior to burn down what was
green and a big difference so really
really good
um control this
um this is just a summary of the most
effective options and the most common
used ones in Florida so a lot of Growers
will before transplant will use a
combination of aim and Chateau to burn
down what's there and to give them
residual control or from Oxon and
chateau
fuel use gold and gramoxone and there
are a few that use glyphosate after
transplant there are a lot of Growers
that use glyphosate or gramoxone placato
mix that can be sprayed up to fruit set
but not after just a couple of things
warning with Chateau if you spray it in
Raw Metals it does persist a long time
that's its strength
um but you can there's a risk of if you
have a sandy soil like we do in Florida
and you get a lot of wind or you can
actually have particles of sand blow up
from the fruit if you wait too long to
apply that application you get little
burn marks so something you don't want
to go too close to when you think you're
going to be picking
with glyphosate really common problem is
um this yellowing this is a little bit
of drift when they were spraying it this
is very typical of glyphosate Roundup
damage and strawberries where you see
the growing points and even the buds
down here all kind of Turn of a yellie
twin yellowy twins so you need to be
careful if you're using glyphosate after
transplant careful to do everything you
can to minimize drift
um I'm going to mention this particular
species because we historically did not
have ragweek parthenium in our
strawberries it started down south of
Florida it has since moved rapidly
northward
um now I pretty much see it in all of
our Strawberry Fields a lot of people
mix it up with common ragweed
and really easy to tell them apart if
you look at this picture ragged
parthenium has white veins which common
Ragweed does not
and common Ragweed if you look at the
top that's common or agree a little bit
more finely divided leaf of course the
dead giveaway is these small white
flowers look like little puff clouds
um and then you have
um also the vein as he's really uh sorry
the stem is these really prominent veins
so why why we're concerned about Ragweed
parthenium and why I'm mentioning it
today is we've seen consistently it's
moving rapidly northward and this is
what it looks like just a couple of days
ago in some Fields what they had
terminated with herbicides and you can
see the ragley parthenium is happily
still growing it's very tolerant of
glyphosate and very tolerant of
gramoxone so it will happily grow and if
you don't control those few that are
left
this is a pepper fuel just south of me
and you can see these white lines that
is it filling the row middles between
these rows of peppers and it's very
difficult to manage
and strawberries you only have two
options at the moment
one is Chateau again this is the number
of weeds per pot so we're looking at the
effects of these herbicides on
controlling pre-emerge so putting it
down before the weed comes up
and this NTC is a non-treated control
and then you see three and six ounces of
Chateau give really good control they
won't control the hundred percent but
they do certainly reduce the density
after that the only options is hand
pulling hauling or cultivation there are
no herbicides that can be used within a
strawberry crop to control the species
we do have some products that are
working
and we have spent some time
um working on getting a label for those
strawberries and that will be a national
label
once we make a little bit more progress
so something to consider with this
species if you do see it in Strawberry
Fields it tends to start on the edges on
the field edges
um you need to make sure you remove it
now in Florida we usually terminate all
strawberries at some point either with a
herbicide or with a fumigant herbicide
of course being the most common
um approach and Cape ham or vapeam being
the ones that are used the most often so
this is just a series of pictures where
we looked at different rates of in this
case it's k-pam vapeam basically you get
the same data
and looking at how much it takes to kill
strawberries this is at the end of the
season you want to inject k-pam and the
advantage of doing this is that you not
only terminate strawberries but you kill
the weeds and you also kill seeds in the
soil and pathogens and nematodes
so at 10 gallons per acre you can see
well this red box that
perfectly good
um strawberry control at a very low rate
of 10 gallons per acre so if you have a
nice clean field and not really any pest
pressure and you just want to terminate
your crop this could be an option
although it's going to be more expensive
than herbicides
however if you go to a part of your
field where you have a lot of nutsed
which is the case in this picture and
I'm just using that stage because you
can visually see the difference
at 10 gallons per acre you still have a
lot of green weeds growing because you
don't there's not as much spread and
there just isn't as you get control in
the center this is with one drip tape
but you're not getting control in the
bed edges if you up it to 40 gallons per
acre
they're still a little bit of green but
you get much much better control and
um overall we control which means it's
gonna if it will kill nutsedge on the
edges as killing other pests that also
occur on the bed edges
um we use this type of technique if we
have issues with these diseases like
charcoal rotten strawberry this can be
an effective way to minimize
um
chance of infection the following year
we've done a lot of studies looking at
rates
so you can see this is a non-treated and
Petri dishes these black dots this is
actually macro firmina growing and petri
dish
at 10 gallons per acre you drop it in
the center but the sides still pretty
bad 20 gallons per acre similar story 30
gallons per acre this yellow is not
um macro firmina this is a different
organism that's not of concern but
you're still not reaching the side at 40
gallons per acre you start to get much
better control so crop termination with
vapam helps with diseases but it also
helps with weeds so for example the most
commonly we have in strawberries in
Florida is goose grass
and if you look at this chart here this
is the dose of metam potassium or kpam
this is percent control and you can see
and this is control not of the plants
this is control of the seeds and this is
what's really important is you can get
significant kill of a seed bank with a
good application
of something like K Camp and this rate
right about here would be equivalent to
40 gallons per acre which means that
around 40 gallons per acre you're going
to get decent control of seeds uh common
personal in another weed that we have a
lot of this would be a very similar
Trend you can see decent control of the
application of kpam
so
summary 10 gallons per acre will
adequately terminate a strawberry crop
but you need much higher rates right
around 40 gallons per acre acre if you
want to optimize weed control and
control of a lot of pathogens like macro
firmina
I do want to mention a follow program so
our season of course is a little
different than yours but generally
speaking we are fumigating and putting
beds in in August we plant in September
and we're harvesting through till March
or April depending on markets and things
like that that means we have a file a
program in from April all the way
through to the following June
um
all right April May and June sometimes
in July and then perhaps part of August
so several months there where we have
bare ground
a little over 80 percent somewhere
around 85 percent of the strawberry
acreage is cover crop every year
um there's a lot of important reasons
for us to do that that's our wettest
time of the year so cover crops help
with things like erosion
um and helping improve a water uptake
for our aquifers
but cover crops also do inhibit weeds
you can see this picture on the right
hand side taken underneath the canopy
um see hardly almost no weed seeds
germinating there so a good cover crop
inhibits wheat growth and suppresses
weed seed production
and can emphasize the importance of you
know there's all kinds of reasons to
cover crop for soil structure for soil
Health but just in terms of weed control
you can really reduce
um weed growth and prevent seed
production
with a properly managed cover crop now
that's true for broadleaf weeds and it's
true for grass seeds and actually in
some of our long-term trials the
presence or absence of a good follow-up
program whether that's cover crops or
herbicides was more important than
deciding which fumigate to use that just
kind of gives you an idea of how
important a good fellow program is that
decision of what to grow when you didn't
have strawberries there had a much
greater effect on what the number of
weeks than even what fumigating selected
when it comes to nutsedge management
cover crops are not a good option and
the reason for that is not such will
happily grow underneath the canopy of
even the most dense cover crops this is
a picture of sun hemp even under Sun
hemp which can form an incredibly thick
canopy uh cover um and that said you'll
continue to happily grow
now it won't produce as many tubers so
you do prevent your populations from
getting bigger which is good
but you don't reduce the population so
if you have a field with a nut such
problem
you're much better off to use something
like cultivation and glyphosate
combinations
so basically what you want to do is you
want to allow the nuts Edge to grow you
want to spray
um glyphosate when you have not said
about I don't know seven inches tall if
certainly before it flowers then you
want to cultivate to stimulate more
um sprouting and then spray again doing
that a couple times will optimize your
not such control
so that kind of gives you a summary of
the overall
um approach to lead control there's one
other thing I want to cover here shortly
but again I want to emphasize the one
thing that we have know for certain is
that effective we control over long term
is you've got to integrate more than one
tool at a time and
one of the reasons that we don't have as
many issues with herbicide resistance
for example in many specialty crops like
strawberries is because we have
historically used very integrated weed
Management Programs so you want to
continue to make sure
that you do that
we've um last few years we've been doing
something kind of fun I'm just going to
mention this quickly uh here in Florida
we do this practice of relay cropping
where we plant a second crop into our
strawberries so
um in this case you can see eggplants
growing in strawberries what would
happen is somewhere around January which
is when we're
full out harvesting strawberries
they will come through and they'll plant
eggplants cantaloupes or peppers in down
the center of the bed so we grow two
rows of strawberries in one bed with one
drip tape down the center so they'll
plant a second crop right down the
center along the side of that drip tape
and then when it comes near the end of
the strawberry season the standard
practice right now would be to remove
those strawberries by hand and allow
that second crop to grow
so the advantage and the reason they do
relay cropping versus terminating the
strawberries and then planting a second
crop it's all about timing it allows
them to get another crop to Market
sooner
um without the gap between when one crop
ends and another one starts
and um there's that there's that
advantage of timing the strawberries do
provide some protection so it allows you
to get basically it allows you to get
two crops in a time period when you
normally couldn't get them because the
part of that time they're growing
together
the downside of this approach is it as
you can imagine hand removal of
strawberries is labor intensive
so we started
um developing this Shield which is
really very simple this is just a
prototype it's basically a triangular
Shield that you can adjust the width at
the bottom
and then on the outside on each side we
have nozzles
I'll just show you the back of it as
well
and we have at the front is kind of
flanged out slightly so what it does is
as you pull through the field in this
case I'm showing you with eggplants
again it pulls the leaves of the
eggplant up and into this triangular
shield and then you're spraying the
herbicide on the outside to kill the
strawberries
so when you pass an open area you can
see this dry line down the center of the
bed that's where the herbicide didn't
touch which is and your plant is covered
and then this wet area on the outside
both sides that's where the herbicide
would have been sprayed
so what this looks like is right here
the strawberries eventually die and you
are continue to grow in this case we're
testing hand removal versus herbicide
removal in eggplants we've done in
cantaloupes and we've also done it in
peppers
not a great idea for cantaloupes but for
Peppers anything growing upright like
peppers and eggplants is a great idea it
works really well
and
um no no effects on yield as a matter of
fact if you plant the second crop at the
right time you actually get a bit of a
yield boost
um just because as I started to mention
earlier the strawberries provide some
level of protection
against cold periods or colder weather
or wind
so with that I want to I know I've gone
kind of long already and I want to make
sure if there's any questions there's a
chance to ask those but um I want to
acknowledge I've got a great team down
here there's a lot of there's a lot of
this work for me and we're funded by the
sort of strawberry Growers the social
Association as well as the Florida
Department of Agriculture